what's up GQ this is Cuddy and I'm gonna
take you through some of my iconic
tracks reborn it was one of those things
where I kind of wanted to make a song
that kind of let the world know where I
was at at that moment in time I had the
hook immediately and it took me a while
to come up with the verses cuz the hook
was so good I was just like how can I
follow that up it's one of those things
that kind of came to us we were working
on it at my house me and dot we just
always kind of did spots ideas and I had
him help me with that and he made it
better
we got Evan masse to come in and do a
little bit at the end like switch to
beat up and add some stuff playing Pat
and had some stuff to the drums that was
definitely one of the first ones that we
had on the album one of the first songs
that we knew we were gonna keep Kanye
went crazy for it and I was really happy
that he liked that joint cuz I was
rooting for it it meant a lot to me I
just needed a record like that at the
time and I thought it was just perfect I
just love it it's just everything about
it the melodies the hook what is what
it's saying you know everything about it
cutting montage we were working on it I
think we were on tour and I had the idea
to sample Kurt Cobain from montage of
heck directed by Brett Morgan the
amazing Brett Morgan I was sitting with
this idea for the longest and I didn't
know if it would be any good I didn't
know if it would work but I kind of
presented it to dot and then told him
how I wanted to chop it up and then bill
my engineer chopped it up and then we
added drums to it and then it just kind
of came out like that it was just a
beautiful marriage everything came
together and a half Kanye on it really
just takes it to another level that was
one of those things where Kanye was like
you know I know you got some more [ __ ]
in that laptop now it's just saying I
don't know I got this one joint
I definitely think Nirvana
big influence on my music trying new
things pushing the envelope pushing
boundaries Kurt he's always been an
inspiration with all that it's like the
world gets to see what it would sound
like if you were around today and I
tried to use him as my muse whenever I
can when you're working on samples
there's always that thought that maybe
this won't get cleared but my first
album there was a couple samples that we
had to take out and I remember I being
so crushed
but we were able to come up with some
cool stuff to replace it and I was
really happy with that but this was a
circumstance where you know we were able
to get it cleared and it was kind of
crazy
cuz I didn't know if we were gonna get
it cleared and Courtney and I believe
Francis had something to do with it too
so Thank You Francis and Courtney father
stretched my hands I worked on that song
in LA with Kanye it was one of those
things where he had the hook already and
I sang it and it was one of those things
where he just knew it was gonna sound
good
I came out with dope but I didn't know
if he was gonna keep it I never really
know what he'll use so it's always a
surprise I think he just likes to see
what what he can do and all the options
and have him in front of him it has that
sense of freedom you know blessings it's
just it's just an anthem especially when
it's on his album I'm always trying to
come up with like an anthem or something
like a hymn you know I'm gonna take him
to church when I can I immediately knew
that that was gonna resonate with the
fans and I was gonna be like a favorite
so it was dope to see you know I loved
when it came out
all the lights we were working on in LA
it was a lot of people in the studio
this day I was recording there was so
much going on when I was recording my
vocals around me so I didn't know nobody
was really paying attention I really had
no clue I was gonna be used there was so
many people already that he had recorded
for the song that came out and was
another surprise like holy [ __ ]
[Music]
and then we did the music video with hi
Williams which is like the illest
it was my first time working with them I
definitely want to work with him again
and to be honest on Rihanna I was really
pumped about that Elton John all these
amazing people to just be in the room
and be on a song with these amazing
artists it's a blessing it's just really
wild it's crazy you know it's just like
what else can we do keep pushing the
envelope
keep pushing boundaries try new [ __ ]